This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. I recently found myself speaking to a group of high school students. There were lots of questions about the worlds of podcasting and journalism, about the rise of AI, and about physical and emotional well-being. But looming over all the questions was the big one. What should I do with my life? High school students are not the only ones with that question. Young adults in college agonize about their majors. 30 and 40-somethings worry about whether they are on the right
这里是《Hidden Brain》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。最近，我发现自己正在与一群高中生交谈。他们提出了许多关于播客和新闻业、人工智能的兴起，以及身心健康的问题。但在所有问题背后，有一个最核心的困惑：我的人生该怎么办？不仅是高中生有这样的疑问，大学生为专业选择而苦恼，三四十岁的人担心自己是否走在正确的
track. 60 and 70-year-olds look back on their lives and ask, is this all there is? At every age and every stage, many of us are intimidated by the question of what we should do with the remaining days we have left. The older we get, the more we realize that time is fleeting. A lifespan of a few decades is but a blink of an eye in the grand scheme of the planet to say nothing of the universe. How can we spend this time meaningfully? This week on Hidden Brain and in a companion story on Hidden Brain Plus, we
轨道上，六七十岁的人回顾一生，不禁自问：难道这就是全部吗？无论处于什么年龄或阶段，我们许多人都被“余生该如何度过”这个问题所困扰。我们越年长，就越意识到时光飞逝。在地球乃至整个宇宙的宏大尺度下，几十年的寿命不过是转瞬即逝。我们该如何有意义地度过这段时光？本周在《Hidden Brain》以及《Hidden Brain Plus》的配套故事中，我们
explore the science of finding a life that is meaningful. There is no one-size- fits-all answer for everyone, but there are scientifically tested ideas about how we can feel more in harmony with ourselves and the world and what happens to our minds and bodies when we come to see our lives with pride and happiness rather than regret. what happens to our minds and bodies when we come to see our lives with pride and happiness, rather than regret. Imagine for a moment that you've inherited an extraordinarily complex and mysterious contraption, one that arrives without operating instructions. In the absence of a manual, you'd have to figure out how it works, the most skillful
将探索寻找有意义人生的科学。对于每个人来说，并没有标准答案，但有一些经过科学验证的理念，可以帮助我们与自我及世界达成更和谐的状态。当我们学会以自豪和幸福而非遗憾的眼光看待生活时，我们的身心会发生什么变化？想象一下，你继承了一台极其复杂且神秘的装置，但它没有任何操作说明。在没有手册的情况下，你必须弄清楚它是如何运作的，最巧妙的
way to operate it, and most importantly, what it's for. This is the situation all of us find ourselves in with our minds. The human brain is capable of extraordinary things. It can invent new products, dream up new ideas, cultivate relationships. With so many options before us, many of us ask, what is it that I am meant to do? At the University of Michigan, Victor Strecker has pondered these questions for many years. Vic Strecker, welcome to Hidden Brain.
操作方式是什么，最重要的是，它的用途是什么。这就是我们所有人面对自己大脑时的处境。人类的大脑能够创造非凡的事物。它可以发明新产品、构思新想法、培养人际关系。面对如此多的选择，我们许多人会问：我注定要做什么？在密歇根大学，维克·斯特雷克多年来一直在思考这些问题。维克·斯特雷克，欢迎来到《Hidden Brain》。
Thank you so much. Happy to be here. Vic, I want to talk about your own journey to discover what you should be doing with your life. In 1990, your daughter Julia was born. Tell me about the first few months of her life. In 1990, your daughter Julia was born. Tell me about the first few months of her life. Yeah, well, Julia was born, as she used to like to say, a 10 out of 10, so she was born healthy. I was a professor, an assistant professor at the University of North Carolina in Chapel Hill.
非常感谢。很高兴来到这里。维克，我想谈谈你探索人生使命的旅程。1990年，你的女儿朱莉娅出生了。跟我讲讲她出生后的头几个月吧。1990年，你的女儿朱莉娅出生了。跟我讲讲她出生后的头几个月吧。是的，朱莉娅出生时，正如她自己常说的那样，是“满分十分”，她很健康。当时我是北卡罗来纳大学教堂山分校的一名助理教授。
And soon after she was born, we went to the Netherlands where I was doing a research sabbatical. Soon she started getting sick. Doctors there diagnosed it as just having some type of respiratory illness, but it seemed to keep getting worse. Finally, she ended up in the hospital in the Netherlands. She was there for a few days and they just didn't know what to do. And then late one evening,
她出生后不久，我们去了荷兰，我在那里进行研究休假。很快她开始生病。那里的医生诊断她只是患了某种呼吸道疾病，但病情似乎一直在恶化。最终，她住进了荷兰的医院。她在那里待了几天，医生们束手无策。直到一天深夜，
a cardiologist just happened to walk by, looked at her and said, she doesn't look quite right. Took an echo machine, an echocardiogram and did the echo on her. And I'll never forget this because it was very late at night. He called a resident in, brought us to a small room, and said, I'm really sorry to tell you this, but your daughter's heart is ruined. And he described it almost as a chicken breast that's been smashed down, pulverized to make it tender, said her heart is really completely destroyed and she has no more than a month
一位心脏科医生恰好路过，看了她一眼说：“她看起来不太对劲。”他拿来一台超声心动图仪，为她做了检查。我永远不会忘记那一刻，因为当时已经是深夜了。他叫来一名住院医生，把我们带到一个小房间，说：“我很抱歉告诉你们，你们女儿的心脏已经毁了。”他形容那颗心脏就像一块被捣碎、为了变嫩而捶打过的鸡胸肉，说她的心脏已经完全坏死，最多只有一两个月的
or two to live. Devastated by the news, Vic and his wife flew back with Julia and her older sister to the United States. They rushed Julia to the medical school at the University of North Carolina. The doctors there confirmed the urgency of the situation, but they offered a silver lining. After doing a lot of tests, they said,
生命了。听到这个消息，维克和妻子悲痛欲绝，带着朱莉娅和她的大姐姐飞回了美国。他们火速将朱莉娅送往北卡罗来纳大学医学院。那里的医生证实了情况的紧迫性，但他们提供了一线希望。在做了大量检查后，他们说：
you know, her other organs have not failed. She might be okay and eligible for a heart transplant. And we have a new surgeon who just came from Stanford. He's not done a heart transplant yet here. And this would be the first heart transplant in the southeastern region of the United States. There was one girl waiting for a heart transplant and she died waiting. So if you'd like to do that, we could put her on a list. Well our world was kind of turned upside down.
“你知道，她的其他器官没有衰竭。她或许还有救，符合心脏移植的条件。我们有一位刚从斯坦福大学来的新外科医生。他在这里还没做过心脏移植手术。这将是美国东南部地区首例心脏移植手术。之前有一个女孩在等待心脏移植时去世了。所以，如果你愿意，我们可以把她列入名单。”我们的世界瞬间天翻地覆。
First it was turned upside down thinking that she was going to die. The second part was turned upside down because now she might have a chance to live. But what kind of life would that be? So I went to the medical school library and I started reading through, you know, pediatric heart transplantation. And the first thing I realized is that we were on the front wave of heart transplants for kids in 1990. Not that many had been done. There weren't that many studies.
起初，想到她会死，世界崩塌了；接着，想到她可能还有一线生机，世界再次天翻地覆。但那会是怎样的人生呢？于是我去了医学院图书馆，开始阅读关于小儿心脏移植的资料。我意识到的第一件事是，我们在1990年处于儿童心脏移植的前沿。当时做过的手术并不多，研究也很少。
But the studies that I did read said roughly 50% of children waiting for a heart die before they get one. And then if they did get a new heart, their chance of surviving five years was 50%. So you can do the math yourself. It's 50% times 50%. Her chance of living to be six years old was 25%. And so we had dinner table conversations. Should we do this?
但我读到的研究显示，大约50%等待心脏的儿童在获得心脏前就去世了。即使他们得到了新心脏，五年生存率也只有50%。所以你可以自己算算，50%乘以50%，她活到六岁的几率只有25%。于是，我们在餐桌上进行了讨论：我们应该这样做吗？
Should we get a transplant? I understand that when you and your wife and your older daughter Rachel were talking about this, the gravity of the situation also meant that you were asking yourself even bigger questions. What does it mean to live a good life? What is a life worth living? Exactly. We started asking ourselves, what is a big life? If she does live to just be six, could we give her a life still worth living
我们应该接受移植吗？我明白，当你和妻子以及大女儿瑞秋讨论这件事时，局势的严峻也意味着你在问自己更宏大的问题。什么才是美好的人生？什么样的人生值得一活？确实。我们开始问自己，什么是“伟大的人生”？如果她只能活到六岁，我们还能给她一个值得一活的人生吗？
if she died at the age of six? And we all got together at the dinner table, what we like to call our gathering place, and we decided, yes, we can give her a big life. Not just within our family, but hopefully she'll have friends. Hopefully she could engage in activities that other children engage in. Hopefully she could develop great friendships and new passions in her life, no matter how long she lived. So I understand you went ahead and got Julia the heart transplant, but this also changed
如果她在六岁时去世了？我们全家聚在餐桌旁——我们称之为“聚会之地”——我们决定：是的，我们可以给她一个伟大的人生。不仅是在家庭内部，希望她还能有朋友。希望她能参与其他孩子参与的活动。希望她无论活多久，都能发展出伟大的友谊和新的热情。所以我明白，你最终还是让朱莉娅接受了心脏移植，但这是否也改变了
the way you were thinking about your own life, your own career troubles or challenges, your own anxieties. How did it change how you approached your life, Vic? It's so funny, as an assistant professor, I was so interested in moving up, getting tenure, becoming an associate professor, getting grants. I thought that was the game, that's what I had to play. And I viewed it kind of as a game.
你对自己人生的看法，对职业困境或挑战、焦虑的看法？维克，这改变了你对待生活的方式吗？这很有趣，作为一名助理教授，我当时非常热衷于晋升、获得终身教职、成为副教授、申请经费。我以为那就是游戏规则，我必须参与其中。我把它看作是一场游戏。
And I was quite honestly fairly good at that game. And so I enjoyed it. I spent a lot of my time on it. And suddenly when Julia got sick, it really changed that. It stopped becoming a game. And I started thinking, I have this one life to live. I don't know how long I'm gonna live. Maybe I'll die in six years or sooner.
老实说，我玩这个游戏玩得还不错。所以我很享受，把大部分时间都花在上面。突然间，朱莉娅生病了，这一切都变了。它不再是一场游戏。我开始想，我只有这一生可活。我不知道自己能活多久。也许我会在六年内死去，甚至更早。
I'm gonna have to live this life as if, you know, this is all I have. And once I started doing that, I started taking my life much more seriously, to be honest. I started thinking more about, well, what would people say about me after I die? What would be on my headstone? What would people say at my memorial service, what kind of legacy would I leave? And I started realizing
我必须像对待仅有的一次生命那样去生活。一旦我开始这样做，说实话，我开始更认真地对待生活。我开始思考：我死后人们会怎么评价我？我的墓碑上会写什么？在我的追悼会上人们会说什么？我会留下什么样的遗产？我开始意识到
that this is the life we live and we better make the most of it given the situations that we're in. So, Julia ended up beating the odds in many ways because the heart transplant she got lasted way more than five years. But by the time she was nine, doctors were telling her that she might need to get a second heart transplant. What happened, Vic? Well, I remember when she was nine, I was coaching her softball team. And by the way, she was a terrible softball player. I think in an entire season, she got one hit and that was a fluke. So not very athletic. At the same time, she loved being with her friends and loved being part
这就是我们所拥有的生活，鉴于我们所处的境遇，我们最好充分利用它。所以，朱莉娅在很多方面都战胜了困难，因为她获得的心脏移植存活时间远超五年。但当她九岁时，医生告诉她可能需要第二次心脏移植。维克，发生了什么？嗯，我记得她九岁时，我正在执教她的垒球队。顺便说一句，她是个糟糕的垒球手。我想整个赛季她只击中了一次球，那还是运气好。所以她不太擅长运动。与此同时，她喜欢和朋友在一起，喜欢成为
of the softball team and I loved coaching. And I remember after one game we were walking home and she passed out and I realized something wrong is happening now. So, you know, took her to the docs and the cardiologist gave her a careful exam and said, yeah, she is going to need a new heart. Julia got on the heart transplant list again. She moved into the hospital, but she wasn't high on the list because her medical condition was not dire. Keeping in mind his commitment to give Julia as normal a life as possible, Vic helped Julia keep up with what her classmates were learning at school.
垒球队的一员，我也喜欢执教。我记得有一次比赛后，我们走在回家的路上，她晕倒了，我意识到现在出问题了。所以，带她去看医生，心脏科医生给她做了仔细检查，说：“是的，她需要一颗新心脏。”朱莉娅再次被列入心脏移植名单。她住进了医院，但因为病情并不危急，所以排名不高。为了履行给朱莉娅尽可能正常生活的承诺，维克帮助朱莉娅跟上学校同学的学习进度。
We were doing Roman numerals. We're studying because she would take her books from school and we would take them to the hospital. So we were learning Roman numerals and that was great. She was really good at math. And then the nurses kindly let me sleep in a room next to hers. It was empty so I could sleep in the bed. I remember staying up watching the US Open tennis tournament.
我们在学罗马数字。因为她会从学校带书来，我们把书带到医院。所以我们在学罗马数字，那很棒。她数学很好。护士们很友善，让我睡在她隔壁的空房间里。我记得我熬夜看美国网球公开赛。
I watched this tennis player, Todd Martin, play against the player. He was down, I think, two sets to nothing. I just watched this whole thing and it went deep into the night. I just remember thinking, wow, if Todd Martin could win after being down by two sets and he's throwing up on the side of the court too. He was so sick and so tired. He came back to win that match and I thought maybe she can win.
我看着网球选手托德·马丁与对手比赛。他当时落后两盘，我想是0比2。我看了整场比赛，一直持续到深夜。我记得当时想：哇，如果托德·马丁在落后两盘的情况下还能赢，而且他在球场边还在呕吐。他病得那么重，那么累。他最终逆转赢得了比赛，我想也许她也能赢。
Well, it's funny that evening I was asleep and I was woken up by the nurse around one o'clock in the morning and the nurse had tears in her eyes and I knew something was wrong. Said Julia's had six heart attacks since you've been asleep and they've been working on her, but things don't look good. I went down to where they were working on her in the ICU, and the doctors took me aside. I called my wife. She drove in from home, and the doctor said, it looks like she has brain dead. Her eyes are fixed and dilated. She hasn't responded to a test where they take a scalpel and scrape the bottom of your foot, which is torturous if you're awake. And they were talking about next steps,
嗯，很有趣，那天晚上我睡着了，凌晨一点左右被护士叫醒，护士眼里含着泪水，我知道出事了。她说朱莉娅在你睡着后心脏骤停了六次，他们一直在抢救她，但情况不容乐观。我走到重症监护室，医生把我拉到一边。我给妻子打了电话。她从家里开车赶来，医生说：“看起来她已经脑死亡了。她的瞳孔固定且散大。她对用手术刀刮脚底的测试没有反应，如果清醒的话，这会非常痛苦。”他们开始讨论下一步，
what to do. And so we went in to see her, and it didn't look like she was there. Her eyes were wide open, her pupils were fixed, dilated. She had no response. And we came back and talked to the doctor, and Jerry, my wife, had the foresight, and I think transcending foresight, to ask the doctor, is there any hope for donating her organs to other people? Because she was at the time on a respirator, and we were talking about the possibility of pulling the respirator out and just letting her go peacefully. And the doctor said, well, yeah, that is possible. Some of her organs might be donated to other people. It'll take a while though because the harvest team needs to fly in to do that. They call it a harvest team. Interesting. And so they would need to fly in. So while the harvest team was flying in,
该怎么办。于是我们进去看她，她看起来已经不在了。她双眼圆睁，瞳孔固定散大。她没有任何反应。我们出来和医生谈话，我的妻子杰瑞有远见，我认为是超越常人的远见，她问医生：“捐献她的器官给其他人还有希望吗？”因为当时她靠呼吸机维持，我们正在讨论拔掉呼吸机让她平静离去的可能性。医生说：“嗯，是的，这是可能的。她的一些器官可以捐献给其他人。但这需要一点时间，因为器官获取小组需要飞过来做这件事。”他们称之为“获取小组”。很有趣。所以他们需要飞过来。当获取小组正在飞过来时，
which is going to take a matter of hours, we walked into the Arboretum at the University of Michigan. It's a beautiful park. And I remember we looked up into the sky and I said, you know, we're not gonna be a, we're not gonna be a foursome anymore. We're gonna be a trio, but we'll still make good music. And we came back and saw her cardiologist, the senior cardiologist who said, before we do anything, maybe you just want to see her one last time. And so we went down to the ICU and I'll never forget this, she was moving.
这需要几个小时，我们走进了密歇根大学的植物园。那是一个美丽的公园。我记得我们抬头望向天空，我说：“你知道，我们不再是四口之家了。我们将成为三人组，但我们依然会奏出美妙的乐章。”我们回来见了她的心脏科医生，那位资深医生说：“在做任何决定前，也许你们想最后再看她一眼。”于是我们去了重症监护室，我永远不会忘记，她在动。
Her eyes were still wide open, fixed dilated, but she was moving spastically. And a neurologist was studying her and examining her. And we said, what is that? Said, this could be the last throes of life. This often happens where you become kind of spastic in your movements. So I just held her hand and I just said, Julie, if you can hear me, squeeze my hand. And I thought I felt a really, really light squeeze. And I turned to the doctor and said, I think she squeezed my hand. And the doctor said, okay, and you could tell what he was thinking.
她的眼睛依然圆睁，固定散大，但她在痉挛性地移动。一位神经科医生正在研究和检查她。我们问：“那是什么？”他说：“这可能是生命最后的挣扎。这种情况经常发生，你会出现痉挛性的动作。”所以我只是握住她的手说：“朱莉，如果你能听到我，捏捏我的手。”我以为我感觉到了一次非常、非常轻微的捏动。我转向医生说：“我想她捏了我的手。”医生说：“好吧。”你可以看出他在想什么。
Everybody feels that squeeze probably. And I was thinking, okay, if she's somehow functioning inside, if she's mentally impaired now because she's gone through six cardiac arrests over a period of five hours, if she's mentally impaired, she'll never get a new heart. She'll be dropped from the list. And I don't want her to go through more suffering. So what kind of tests could I provide to her right now in this case? So I whispered in her ear, if you can hear me, Julia, squeeze my hand IV times in Roman
每个人可能都会感觉到那种捏动。我在想，如果她内心还在运作，如果她因为在五小时内经历了六次心脏骤停而导致精神受损，如果她精神受损，她就永远得不到新心脏了。她会被从名单上除名。我不想让她经历更多的痛苦。所以我现在能给她什么测试呢？于是我在她耳边低语：“如果你能听到我，朱莉娅，用罗马数字捏我的手四次。”她捏了我的手四次。
numerals. And she squeezed my hand four times. And I turned to the doctor and said, she squeezed my hand four times. And the doctor turned pale. And suddenly there were about ten people working on her. They had already pulled all her tubes out and they put all the tubes back in basically. And the doctors said, this has never happened to us before. We've never seen this happen. And I didn't blame them whatsoever. They did everything according to protocol. They did everything that was supposed to be done. And yet somehow she was in there and she was alive and gradually she started coming back, started asking her things and she could nod her head. Gradually she started being able to communicate with us.
我转向医生说：“她捏了我的手四次。”医生脸色苍白。突然间，大约有十个人在抢救她。他们之前已经拔掉了她所有的管子，现在基本上又把所有管子插了回去。医生说：“这在我们这里从未发生过。我们从未见过这种情况。”我一点也不怪他们。他们完全按照规程办事，做了所有该做的事。然而不知何故，她还在那里，她还活着，渐渐地她开始恢复，开始问她问题，她能点头。渐渐地，她开始能与我们交流。
She couldn't speak because she had a respirator. She was blind, and in fact, she was blind for at least a couple of days because the part of her brain that relates to sight actually didn't get enough oxygen. So I was also making my own calculations. Okay, so maybe she'll be blind. We can manage that for sure. But she knows what aromannumerals are, so I think she's not cognitively impaired. So she waited for a heart for a couple days.
她因为插着呼吸机无法说话。她失明了，事实上，她失明了至少几天，因为她大脑中与视觉相关的部分确实没有获得足够的氧气。所以我也在做自己的计算。好吧，也许她会失明。我们肯定能应付。但她知道什么是罗马数字，所以我认为她没有认知障碍。所以她等了几天心脏。
She was placed number one in the country for a heart transplant, and she received a new heart. Her blindness went away, and even within a week, we brought a small electric piano because she'd been learning to play the piano. And she was sitting up, she was playing Bach on the piano, and the head of cardiology walked in, and as she was playing Bach on the piano, she was only nine years old, the doctor just started crying and just said, I think this is a miracle. I don't know how else to say it. When we come back, Julia's journey changes how Vic decides to live the rest of his life. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta.
她被列为全国心脏移植名单的第一位，并获得了一颗新心脏。她的失明消失了，甚至在一周内，我们带去了一架小型电子琴，因为她一直在学弹钢琴。她坐了起来，在钢琴上弹奏巴赫，心脏科主任走进来，当她弹奏巴赫时，她才九岁，医生开始哭泣，只是说：“我想这是一个奇迹。我不知道还能怎么说。”稍后回来，朱莉娅的旅程改变了维克决定余生如何生活的方式。你正在收听《Hidden Brain》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。
This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. Victor Strecker's daughter was a fighter. Julia received a heart transplant before she was a year old, and another one at age nine. She made it through middle school and high school. Inspired by the many nurses who had cared for her, she enrolled in nursing school. When Julia was in nursing school, her first year, she was really struggling. The first semester, she was having a hard time. She had a lot of headaches. She was pretty sick, quite a bit, but she was trying to work through it.
这里是《Hidden Brain》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。维克多·斯特雷克的女儿是个斗士。朱莉娅在一岁前就接受了心脏移植，九岁时又接受了一次。她读完了初中和高中。受曾照顾她的许多护士的启发，她报名参加了护理学校。当朱莉娅在护理学校读大一时，她真的很挣扎。第一学期，她过得很艰难。她经常头痛。她病得很重，相当频繁，但她一直在努力克服。
She lived in a dorm, and I would meet with her every once in a while, because I was a professor there at the university so we could have lunch together. And she was having a tough time. So I said, well, how about if we go down to the Caribbean? We go to someplace warm because it's very cold and I think she was feeling the cold weather much more than other people, maybe because her heart was having a hard time. She had passed other tests of her heart, but this was 10 years past her previous heart transplant. She was 19 years old.
她住在宿舍里，我会偶尔和她见面，因为我是那所大学的教授，所以我们可以一起吃午饭。她过得很艰难。所以我说：“嗯，我们要不要去加勒比海？去个暖和的地方，因为这里太冷了，我觉得她比其他人更怕冷，也许是因为她的心脏负担很重。”她通过了心脏的其他检查，但这距离她上次心脏移植已经过去10年了。她19岁了。
So we took her to the Caribbean along with her sister, and we took their boyfriends with us as well. And I remember on the third night, we were all out on the beach at the gathering place. We had a table out on the beach and we were just enjoying it. And we were walking back and she turned to her boyfriend and she said, I'm so happy now that I could die. And it turns out that those were her last words that I heard because she died in the middle of the night, that night of a massive heart attack, very suddenly and very unexpectedly. So at 19 that was the last time we saw her. So about a month after Julia died,
所以我们带她和她的姐姐去了加勒比海，我们也带上了她们的男朋友。我记得在第三天晚上，我们都在海滩上的聚会点。我们在海滩上放了一张桌子，我们只是在享受这一切。我们走回去时，她转向她的男朋友说：“我现在太幸福了，即使现在死去也无憾。”事实证明，这是我听到的她的遗言，因为那天晚上，她在睡梦中因突发严重心脏病去世了，非常突然，非常意外。所以19岁那年是我们最后一次见到她。所以朱莉娅去世大约一个月后，
you were giving a talk about health and wellness. This is the focus of your research. And right before your talk, another researcher was talking about the effects of stressful events on workplace productivity. What did he say, Vic? Well, I remember he started talking about different stressors, like if you get sick, you will lose on average this many days of work.
你正在做一个关于健康和幸福的演讲。这是你研究的重点。就在你演讲前，另一位研究人员正在谈论压力事件对工作效率的影响。维克，他说了什么？嗯，我记得他开始谈论不同的压力源，比如如果你生病了，平均会损失这么多天的工作。
If you have other issues happen to you, if you get a divorce, you'll have this many days on average loss of work. If you lose a loved one, you lose this many days on average of work. And then he stopped for a second and he said, but if you lose a child, that exceeds all other amounts of work that you lose. You're kind of lost for a very, very long time and most people don't ever come back to work fully after losing their child. And I had just lost my child. I wanted to say, you
如果你遇到其他问题，如果你离婚了，平均会损失这么多天的工作。如果你失去了一个亲人，平均会损失这么多天的工作。然后他停顿了一下说：“但如果你失去了一个孩子，那超过了所有其他损失的工作量。你会迷失很长很长一段时间，大多数人在失去孩子后永远无法完全回到工作中。”而我刚刚失去了我的孩子。我想说：
know, I'm sorry buddy, but I'm not going to be one of those people you're talking about. And I completely disagree that you have to assume that you're not going to continue working and thriving and continuing with your life. You can do that. And I didn't say that in my own speech, but I sure felt it. At the same time, Vic, you and your family had made Julia the purpose of your life for essentially 20 years, and Julia was gone now. I understand that at one point you retreated alone to a cabin in northern Michigan. What did you do there? When Julia died, I remember my wife and I went to a therapist, a grief counselor,
“你知道，抱歉伙计，但我不会成为你谈论的那种人。”我完全不同意你必须假设自己不会继续工作、茁壮成长并继续生活。你可以做到。我在自己的演讲中没有说出来，但我确实是这么感受的。与此同时，维克，你和你的家人基本上20年来一直把朱莉娅当作生活的重心，而现在朱莉娅走了。我听说有一次你独自退隐到密歇根北部的一个小屋里。你在那里做了什么？朱莉娅去世时，我记得我和妻子去看了一位治疗师，一位悲伤咨询师，
who is also a marriage counselor, which is great. And I remember being the smart professor that I am. I went in and said, well, I've done the research and I've read that 80% of couples who lose a child break up. And so that's why we're seeing you, because we want to make sure that our marriage continues to survive." And she kind of smiled gently and said, well, you know, Vic, 50% of marriages end up in divorces anyway.
她也是婚姻咨询师，这很好。我记得作为一名聪明的教授，我走进去说：“嗯，我做过研究，读过文章说80%失去孩子的夫妇会分手。所以这就是我们来看你的原因，因为我们想确保我们的婚姻能继续存续。”她温和地笑了笑说：“嗯，你知道，维克，50%的婚姻最终都会以离婚告终。”
So I forgot to realize that, and of course, so there certainly is a greater risk of getting a divorce if you lose a child, but it doesn't go from zero to 80%. But then she turned to me and said, but I will tell you this, if you judge how your wife, Geri, is grieving or if she judges how you're grieving, maybe you're not grieving enough, maybe you're grieving too much,
所以我忘了这一点，当然，失去孩子确实会增加离婚的风险，但它不会从零直接跳到80%。但随后她转向我说：“但我会告诉你这一点，如果你评判你的妻子杰瑞是如何悲伤的，或者她评判你是如何悲伤的，也许你悲伤得不够，也许你悲伤得太多，
maybe you're doing this and it's not good for you, whatever, you'll split up. So what I recommend you do is you go on your own journeys of grief. You respect the other person's journey of grief. You communicate, but you may end up doing things differently. My wife, who's a sculptor, an artist, and a gardener, started sculpting and gardening more in Ann Arbor. I went up to Northern Michigan to a cabin we had
也许你这样做对你不好，无论怎样，你们都会分开。所以我建议你们各自踏上悲伤的旅程。尊重对方的悲伤旅程。沟通，但你们最终可能会以不同的方式处理。我的妻子，她是一位雕塑家、艺术家和园丁，开始在安娜堡更多地进行雕塑和园艺。我去了我们在密歇根北部的一个小屋，
right in Lake Michigan. And I was by myself for long weeks at a time and I basically started eating and drinking myself to death. I started watching TV all the time. It didn't matter what I was watching, not at all. I just started finding myself almost dissolving. It was like entropy was occurring in my body. It felt like every atom of my's friends sent him books to read.
就在密歇根湖边。我独自一人待了很长几周，我基本上开始通过饮食和酗酒来自我毁灭。我开始一直看电视。看什么都无所谓，一点也不重要。我只是发现自己几乎在消融。就像我的身体里正在发生熵增。感觉我身体的每一个原子……朋友们寄给他书读。
He had taken some of these on his solitary trip to the cabin. Now and then, he would dip into the books. One book was a book of poetry by the Persian poet Rumi, a 13th century poet, an amazing poet. And I wasn't into poetry, I'll be real honest, I didn't read poetry. But I just started paging through it and it seemed like there were letters Rumi was writing to me. And before I went to bed, I read this amazing poem. And if it's all right, I'd like to read just the first piece of this poem. The breeze at dawn has secrets to tell you don't go back to sleep. You must ask for what you really want. Don't go back to sleep.
他带了一些书去小屋进行孤独的旅行。偶尔，他会翻翻这些书。其中一本是波斯诗人鲁米的诗集，一位13世纪的诗人，一位了不起的诗人。我不喜欢诗歌，说实话，我不读诗。但我开始翻阅它，似乎鲁米写给我的信就在里面。睡觉前，我读了这首了不起的诗。如果可以的话，我想读这首诗的第一部分。“黎明时的微风有秘密要告诉你，不要回去睡觉。你必须要求你真正想要的东西。不要回去睡觉。”
People are going back and forth across the door sill where the two worlds touch. People are going back and forth across the door sill where the two worlds touch The door is round and open don't go back to sleep That night I went to sleep And I had a dream that I was with Julia we were rollerblading in the Netherlands in this small, beautiful, medieval town called Maastricht. And we were rollerblading together. She was only nine years old. And we looked out and we saw this beautiful, what looked like a place of worship. It could have been a mosque, it could have been a synagogue, it could have been a church, whatever it was, it was beautiful and marble, stone, it was huge and it was glowing.
“人们在两个世界交汇的门槛上来回穿梭。人们在两个世界交汇的门槛上来回穿梭。门是圆的，敞开的，不要回去睡觉。”那天晚上我睡着了。我做了一个梦，梦见我和朱莉娅在一起，我们在荷兰一个美丽的中世纪小镇马斯特里赫特滑旱冰。我们在一起滑旱冰。她才九岁。我们向外看，看到了一个美丽的、看起来像礼拜场所的地方。它可能是清真寺，可能是犹太教堂，可能是教堂，无论它是什么，它都很美，大理石、石头，它巨大且在发光。
And we rollerbladed there. And then we went into the entrance and right in the entrance was a spiral staircase that went down infinitely. And she said, we need to go down there. And I said, Julia, we can't. We have roller blades on. And we started floating down this spiral staircase. It was a very vivid dream.
我们滑着旱冰去了那里。然后我们进入入口，入口处有一个螺旋楼梯，一直向下延伸，无穷无尽。她说：“我们需要下去。”我说：“朱莉娅，我们不能。我们穿着旱冰鞋。”然后我们开始漂浮着走下那个螺旋楼梯。那是一个非常生动的梦。
And we ended up in this large marble hall room, giant room with a big hallway. And as we entered the room, there are these three beautiful women, and they're all wearing exactly the same dress. They came up, and I turned to look at Julia, and suddenly she was wearing exactly that dress. And she was 19, suddenly, and she said, I have to go. And she turned from me and she walked with these three people, and they all disappeared. I woke up. It was five o'clock in the morning and my pillowcase was just soaked with tears. And I thought, I want to go back to sleep.
我们最终来到了一个巨大的大理石大厅，一个带有大走廊的巨大房间。当我们进入房间时，有三个美丽的女人，她们都穿着完全一样的裙子。她们走过来，我转头看朱莉娅，突然她穿着完全一样的裙子。她突然变成了19岁，她说：“我必须走了。”她转身离开我，和那三个人一起走，她们都消失了。我醒了。当时是凌晨五点，我的枕套被泪水浸透了。我想：我想回去睡觉。
I want to see her again. It was such a vivid dream. I was talking with her. I think I might be able to go back to sleep and talk to Julia. And I remembered the Rumi poem that said, don't go back to sleep and talk to Julia. And I remembered the roomie poem that said, don't go back to sleep. So I looked out right onto Lake Michigan and it was still dark, but I could tell
我想再见到她。那个梦太生动了。我在和她说话。我想我可能能回去睡觉，和朱莉娅说话。我记得鲁米的诗说“不要回去睡觉”，和朱莉娅说话。我记得鲁米的诗说“不要回去睡觉”。所以我看向密歇根湖，天还是黑的，但我能看出
that Lake Michigan was exceedingly calm. Usually there are big waves, it looks like an ocean usually, but it was glassy smooth. And I was just sleeping in a boxers and a t-shirt, but I decided to pop out of bed and I hopped in my kayak. It was still dark. It was still spring. And I started paddling out into the middle of Lake Michigan.
密歇根湖异常平静。通常那里有大浪，看起来像海洋，但它像玻璃一样平滑。我只穿着平角裤和T恤睡觉，但我决定跳下床，跳进我的皮划艇。天还是黑的。还是春天。我开始划向密歇根湖中心。
I just thought, I'm just going to keep paddling. This is so beautiful out here. The water was so cold. I knew if I had fallen in, I would probably drown. I didn't care. I just kept paddling and paddling straight out toward Wisconsin. And Wisconsin is 86 miles away, by the way. But I was thinking, I was about two miles out as far as I could tell,
我只是想：我只要一直划就行了。这里太美了。水太冷了。我知道如果我掉进去，我可能会淹死。我不在乎。我只是不停地划，不停地划，径直朝威斯康星州划去。顺便说一句，威斯康星州在86英里外。但我当时在想，据我所知，我已经划出去了大约两英里，
and I was thinking maybe I'll just keep going. This is so beautiful. And I really don't have anything to live for right now. Suddenly the sun came up. It was 5 15 in the morning. And I saw all the water shimmering around me. I don't know how to explain this, but water will shimmer when it's very, very smooth and the sun was just coming up and everywhere around me it felt like it was glowing. But then suddenly I felt my daughter, Julia, inside me.
我在想也许我会一直划下去。这太美了。而且我现在真的没有什么可活的了。突然太阳升起来了。当时是凌晨5点15分。我看到周围所有的水都在闪烁。我不知道该怎么解释，但当水非常、非常平滑时，水会闪烁，太阳刚刚升起，我周围的一切感觉都在发光。但突然间，我感觉到我的女儿朱莉娅在我体内。
I don't know how else to put it, she was in me and I felt her say, Dad, you've got to get over this. And it wasn't like she was looking at me going, you have to get over this. It was more, you have to get over yourself. You have to get over your ego. You have to get over your grief and think about things bigger than yourself. But you have a choice right now. You can decide to continue on to Wisconsin and you'll never make that of course, or you can turn back. But if you do turn back you're gonna have to change your life. I stayed out there for quite a few minutes thinking about this and the sun was coming
我不知道该怎么表达，她在我的体内，我感觉到她说：“爸爸，你必须走出来。”这不像她在看着我说“你必须走出来”。更像是“你必须超越你自己”。你必须超越你的自我。你必须超越你的悲伤，去思考比你自己更宏大的事情。但你现在有一个选择。你可以决定继续前往威斯康星州，当然你永远到不了，或者你可以回头。但如果你回头，你必须改变你的生活。我在那里待了几分钟思考这个问题，太阳升起来了，
up, it was beautiful, and I decided to turn around. I went back, I was cold, just kind of damp. I went right to our kitchen, I pulled a sheet of paper out and said, Vic, you have to help yourself. And I don't know how to explain this either, Vic, you have to help yourself. And I don't know how to explain this either, but it was almost as if I was looking down on myself from the ceiling and just looking at my head, looking at the piece of paper and pen and saying, what are you going to do to help yourself, Vic? Almost like I was my own therapist.
它很美，我决定转身。我回去了，我很冷，浑身湿漉漉的。我直接走到厨房，拿出一张纸说：“维克，你必须帮助你自己。”我不知道该怎么解释，维克，你必须帮助你自己。我不知道该怎么解释，但几乎就像我从天花板上俯视自己，看着我的头，看着纸和笔，说：“维克，你要做什么来帮助你自己？”几乎就像我是我自己的治疗师。
And I said, maybe the first thing I need to do is write down what matters most in my life. And so I literally just started writing my family, Jerry, my wife, Rachel, my daughter. I started writing down my mom, my dad, my siblings. Then I wrote down my friends. Then I started asking myself, what matters at work? They've given you this semester off from teaching. They even gave you the next semester if you need it off from teaching. They said, you lost your daughter. It's one of the hardest things you can go through.
我说：“也许我需要做的第一件事是写下我生命中最重要的事情。”所以我真的开始写下我的家人，杰瑞，我的妻子，瑞秋，我的女儿。我开始写下我的妈妈，我的爸爸，我的兄弟姐妹。然后我写下我的朋友。然后我开始问自己，工作中什么最重要？他们给了我这个学期的教学假。如果需要，他们甚至给了我下个学期的教学假。他们说：“你失去了女儿。这是你能经历的最艰难的事情之一。”
But I started asking myself, what matters most? I do a lot of research, but I said, of everything, my students matter most. And then it dawned on me, I need to get back to teaching. So that morning I called the school and said, I know you gave me this semester and even next semester off if I need it, but quite honestly, it's not the advice I need. I really need to teach, and I want to teach every one of my students as if they're my own daughter, Julia. And that changed my life. When we come back, Vic starts to see connections between the changes he is making in his own
但我开始问自己，什么最重要？我做了很多研究，但我说，在所有事情中，我的学生最重要。然后我意识到，我需要回到教学岗位。那天早上我给学校打电话说：“我知道你们给了我这个学期甚至下个学期的假，如果我需要的话，但老实说，这不是我需要的建议。我真的需要教学，我想像对待我自己的女儿朱莉娅一样对待我的每一位学生。”这改变了我的生活。稍后回来，维克开始看到他正在做出的改变与他作为科学家所研究的事物之间的联系。
life and the things he is studying as a scientist. People with transcending values have less activation in a part of the brain that relates to fear and aggression called the amygdala. They have more activation in a part of the brain that relates to long-term orientation, a future orientation, and that's called the ventral medial prefrontal cortex. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. Victor Strecker is a public health researcher at the University of Michigan.
具有超越性价值观的人，大脑中与恐惧和攻击性相关的部分（称为杏仁核）的激活程度较低。他们大脑中与长期导向、未来导向相关的部分（称为腹内侧前额叶皮层）的激活程度较高。你正在收听《Hidden Brain》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这里是《Hidden Brain》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。维克多·斯特雷克是密歇根大学的公共卫生研究员。
After his daughter's death, he started to explore the science of purpose. He found that a sense of purpose was closely linked to many of the goals of public health research, to help people live longer, better lives. Vic, one of the people you studied was a man named Jerry Hirsch. Tell me his story. Yeah, Jerry out of the blue called me and he said, I'm in my late 70s or early 80s,
在他女儿去世后，他开始探索目的的科学。他发现，目标感与公共卫生研究的许多目标密切相关，即帮助人们过上更长寿、更美好的生活。维克，你研究过的人之一是一个叫杰瑞·赫什的人。讲讲他的故事吧。是的，杰瑞突然给我打电话，他说：“我七十多岁或八十出头了，
it was a while back. And he said, I've built a lot of K-Marts around the Phoenix area. I live in Phoenix and I've become very wealthy as a result of that. And I decided finally, is this my legacy? Basically, you know, before there was Jerry Hirsch, there were 423 K-Marts, now there are 667 K-Marts. Is that what I want my legacy to be? And he said, there has to be something more than that. What will I want on my headstone?
那是很久以前的事了。”他说：“我在凤凰城地区建了很多凯马特超市。我住在凤凰城，结果我变得非常富有。我最终决定，这就是我的遗产吗？基本上，你知道，在杰瑞·赫什之前，有423家凯马特，现在有667家凯马特。这就是我想要的遗产吗？”他说：“一定还有比这更多的东西。我的墓碑上会写什么？”
And he had created a foundation that helps philanthropies, you know, really positive. And he said, I have to tell you, I found that having a strong purpose is the most important thing that I've ever done in my life. I was severely depressed. I realized that money wasn't going to make me happy, especially with the amount I already had,
他创建了一个帮助慈善机构的基金会，你知道，非常积极。他说：“我必须告诉你，我发现拥有一个强大的目标是我一生中做过的最重要的事情。我曾经严重抑郁。我意识到金钱不会让我快乐，尤其是考虑到我已经拥有的数量，
more money wasn't gonna make me happier. I didn't need to be the richest person in the graveyard. And so I found this purpose, which is to help build philanthropic organizations and to support them. And he said, this is actually very selfish. Having a purpose is good for me. So for us, we kind of shared this common perspective that having a purpose can bring you out of
更多的钱不会让我更快乐。我不需要成为坟墓里最富有的人。所以我找到了这个目标，那就是帮助建立慈善组织并支持它们。他说，这其实非常自私。拥有一个目标对我自己有好处。”所以对我们来说，我们分享了这种共同的观点，即拥有一个目标可以让你走出
depression. And I've had since then many people write to me from around the world, frankly, about how finding purpose brought them out of depression. And some people would say, better than any drug, better than any psychotherapy I ever engaged in. engaged in. So your research has found that people with a greater sense of purpose employ different emotion regulation strategies than people who have a weaker sense of purpose.
抑郁。从那时起，坦率地说，有许多来自世界各地的人写信给我，讲述寻找目标是如何让他们走出抑郁的。有些人会说，比我尝试过的任何药物、任何心理治疗都要好。所以你的研究发现，具有更强目标感的人比目标感较弱的人采用不同的情绪调节策略。
Can you describe this finding and also what are emotion regulation strategies and why are they important? Well first of all, we all have stressors in our lives, right? All of us. And the question really is how do you cope with those stressors? Turns out that of 16 coping strategies that we looked at, strategies like drinking alcohol or eating too much or venting were negatively associated with sense of purpose.
你能描述一下这个发现，以及什么是情绪调节策略，为什么它们很重要吗？嗯，首先，我们生活中都有压力源，对吧？我们所有人。真正的问题是你如何应对这些压力源？事实证明，在我们研究的16种应对策略中，像饮酒、暴饮暴食或发泄这样的策略与目标感呈负相关。
Whereas seeing a big picture, knowing this won't last forever, taking walks in nature, engaging in a family or religious ritual, those were strongly associated with a sense of purpose. And along with that, emotional self-regulation. I remember I was talking to a colleague in the business school at Michigan, and he said his son has a child who is in Montessori School, five-year-old child comes home, and they're getting in a big argument,
而着眼于大局、知道这一切不会永远持续下去、在大自然中散步、参与家庭或宗教仪式，这些都与目标感密切相关。随之而来的是情绪自我调节。我记得我曾与密歇根商学院的一位同事交谈，他说他的儿子有一个在蒙台梭利学校上学的孩子，五岁的孩子回家，他们发生了激烈的争吵，
and they're almost yelling at each other. And finally the five-year-old child says, you know what, I'm going to change my own weather. And suddenly they have an adult conversation. And I was thinking, I wish a lot of senior leaders had that ability to change
他们几乎在互相大喊大叫。最后，五岁的孩子说：“你知道吗，我要改变我自己的天气。”突然间，他们进行了成年人的对话。我在想，我希望许多高级领导者也有那种改变的能力。
their own weather, going from cloudy to sunny. And so what that requires, I think, is a sense of understanding what your emotion is, and also having the agency to be able to change it. There's been work that looks at the relationship between having a sense of purpose and feeling more energy and willpower,
他们自己的天气，从阴天转为晴天。我认为，这需要一种对自身情绪的理解，以及能够改变这种情绪的能动性。已有研究探讨了拥有目标感与感受到更多能量和意志力之间的关系，
and in some ways it makes sense. If you're actually driven by something, it feels like you should have more energy and willpower to stick at it. Studies show that if you put a backpack on a person that's 25 pounds and say, this backpack is just dead weight, or put another backpack on another group of people and say, this backpack has important scientific equipment that you're carrying, it's a very important purposeful backpack.
在某种程度上，这是有道理的。如果你确实被某件事所驱动，你似乎就应该有更多的能量和意志力去坚持下去。研究表明，如果你给一个人背上一个25磅重的背包，并告诉他这个背包只是死重，或者给另一组人背上另一个背包，并告诉他们这个背包里装的是重要的科学设备，是一个非常重要且有意义的背包，
equipment that you're carrying. It's a very important purposeful backpack. And you put both of them on a ramp and they estimate how steep the ramp is. The group carrying the purposeful backpack, even though it still just had dead weight, it wasn't carrying scientific equipment, the people carrying that backpack perceive the slope to be far lower.
你所携带的设备。这是一个非常重要且有意义的背包。然后你把他们两个都放在斜坡上，让他们估计斜坡有多陡。背着那个有意义背包的那组人，尽管里面装的仍然只是死重，并没有携带科学设备，但背着那个背包的人感知到的坡度要低得多。
In fact, as if they weren't carrying any backpack. So I think when you have a sense of purpose, just think about if you're trying to swim as a child underwater as far as you can, you might say, okay, I'm gonna try to swim as far as I can. Or I might say, I'm gonna touch the other side of the pool. When you're trying to touch the other side of the pool, you're going to swim further, you're going to devote more persistence to it.
事实上，就好像他们根本没背背包一样。所以我认为，当你有了目标感时，试想一下，如果你小时候试图在水下尽可能远地游泳，你可能会说，好吧，我要试着游得尽可能远。或者我可能会说，我要去触碰泳池的另一边。当你试图触碰泳池的另一边时，你会游得更远，你会投入更多的毅力。
You're going to put up with more pain. You're going to be able to do that. You may not even touch the other side of the pool, but having a goal like that, and that's what purpose is all about. It helps you organize the important goals in your life. It helps you really direct your inner resources, your energy toward that. One other finding that researchers have made is that purpose seems to be linked to a sense of resilience. There was a study in the wake of a devastating earthquake
你会忍受更多的痛苦。你将能够做到这一点。你甚至可能触碰不到泳池的另一边，但拥有这样一个目标，这就是目标的全部意义所在。它能帮助你组织生活中重要的目标。它能帮助你真正地将内在资源和能量导向那个目标。研究人员发现的另一个结论是，目标似乎与韧性有关。在一次毁灭性地震之后，有一项研究
in Pakistan that tracked 200 survivors, most of whom had lost a relative. Tell me what this research study found, Vik. This research and other studies of tsunamis, earthquakes, you know, large tragic events to large populations have shown that the people with a stronger sense of purpose are far more resilient than if you lose purpose. Another good example are soldiers in the Gulf War. Coming back from the Gulf War, many of these soldiers lost their purpose because they had a great sense of purpose while they're at war in combat. If a person could come back and develop a stronger sense of purpose while they're at war, in combat. If a person could come back and develop a stronger sense of purpose,
在巴基斯坦追踪了200名幸存者，其中大多数人失去了亲人。维克，告诉我这项研究发现了什么。这项研究以及其他关于海啸、地震等针对大量人群的大型悲剧事件的研究表明，拥有更强目标感的人比失去目标感的人要坚韧得多。另一个很好的例子是海湾战争中的士兵。从海湾战争回来后，许多士兵失去了目标，因为他们在战争和战斗中有着强烈的目标感。如果一个人回来后能发展出更强的目标感，
they actually were more likely to develop growth, what we'd call post-traumatic growth. So I think that this idea of going through something difficult, there's a possible challenge for you where you could end up becoming a stronger person as a result. Is it possible that purpose is primarily a luxury good? You know, in other words, once you have your basic needs taken care of,
他们实际上更有可能获得成长，也就是我们所说的创伤后成长。所以我认为，经历困难的想法，对你来说可能是一个挑战，结果你可能会成为一个更坚强的人。目标主要是一种奢侈品吗？也就是说，一旦你的基本需求得到满足，
your food, your shelter, your security, then other words, once you have your basic needs taken care of, your food, your shelter, your security, then it's time to think about purpose. I know that's a common belief that having a purpose is almost on the top of Maslow's hierarchy. One good friend of mine, James Aaronateway, grew up in a rural part of Uganda. Both of his parents died when he was very young. I believe by the time he was five, his parents were both dead. He was often called an AIDS orphan. His grandmother took care of him and his grandmother said, I'm going to give you an education. So walked him 300 miles, maybe there is a bus or two in between, I don't know, but he basically said
你的食物、住所、安全，那么是时候考虑目标了。我知道这是一种普遍的信念，即拥有目标几乎处于马斯洛需求层次的顶端。我的一个好朋友詹姆斯·阿伦纳特威（James Aaronateway）在乌干达的一个农村地区长大。他的父母在他很小的时候就去世了。我相信在他五岁时，他的父母都去世了。他常被称为艾滋孤儿。他的祖母照顾他，祖母说，我要让你接受教育。于是带他走了300英里，也许中间有一两辆巴士，我不知道，但他基本上说
that they essentially walked 300 miles to Kampala, the capital of Uganda. And they went to the palace and she talked to the palace guard and said, my son needs to talk to the prime minister because he needs an education. And the guard said, of course, well, they can't see you. And she said, I'll just wait here. And so they waited for weeks. They literally camped out by the palace. And every day they would ask,
他们基本上走了300英里才到达乌干达首都坎帕拉。他们去了宫殿，她和宫殿守卫交谈，说我的儿子需要和总理谈谈，因为他需要接受教育。守卫说，当然，好吧，他们不能见你。她说，我就在这里等。于是他们等了几个星期。他们真的在宫殿旁露营。每天他们都会问，
the grandmother would ask to see the prime minister. And finally, the guard came out and said, we've talked about you and the Prime Minister's wife would like to see you. So suddenly, this is James's chance, goes in and says, I would like an education. And sure enough, he ended up getting an excellent education getting an excellent education at a private school in Kampala. He later on got an advanced degree and then he decided that everyone should have an education. Developed Teach for Uganda, it's become very successful and that has been his purpose. He's an amazing person.
祖母会要求见总理。最后，守卫出来说，我们谈过你们的事了，总理夫人想见你们。所以突然间，这是詹姆斯的机会，他走进去说，我想接受教育。果然，他最终在坎帕拉的一所私立学校接受了良好的教育。他后来获得了高等学位，然后他决定每个人都应该接受教育。他创办了“乌干达为之教”（Teach for Uganda），它变得非常成功，这就是他的目标。他是一个了不起的人。
He laughed when I asked him whether he thought purpose was only for people who had everything else. He said, well, I don't think you Westerners really understand this. Purpose gives poor people hope. Hope for their families, hope for the future. Purpose is absolutely essential for the poor. So researchers have suggested that something called a shift and persist strategy may help explain why a sense of purpose exerts these effects. What is the strategy, Vic? Well, the idea is that coping efforts that help you accommodate to stressors, as opposed to just trying to change stressors, may be an important thing for people who don't have resources for dealing with the stressors or when those resources are really limited. So if you're poor, you might
当我问他是否认为目标只属于那些拥有一切的人时，他笑了。他说，嗯，我不认为你们西方人真正理解这一点。目标给穷人带来了希望。为他们的家庭带来希望，为未来带来希望。目标对穷人来说绝对是必不可少的。因此，研究人员提出，一种被称为“转变与坚持”（shift and persist）的策略可能有助于解释为什么目标感会产生这些影响。维克，这个策略是什么？嗯，这个想法是，帮助你适应压力源的应对努力，而不是仅仅试图改变压力源，对于那些没有资源来处理压力源，或者当这些资源非常有限时的人来说，可能是一件重要的事情。所以如果你很穷，你可能
not be able to control everything in your life. In fact, none of us control everything in our lives. Some therapies work really hard on having you try to control stressors, manage, understand what the stressors are and control them. I think in shift and persist, um, the idea would be the more you're trying to control everything in your life, it's almost like trying to struggle out of quicksand. It may actually have you sink deeper. Not good. But if you try to accommodate the stressors,
无法控制生活中的一切。事实上，我们谁都无法控制生活中的一切。有些疗法非常努力地让你尝试控制压力源，管理、理解压力源是什么并控制它们。我认为在“转变与坚持”中，嗯，这个想法是，你越是试图控制生活中的一切，就越像是试图从流沙中挣扎出来。它实际上可能会让你沉得更深。不好。但如果你尝试适应压力源，
you accept the fact that you will have stressors. At the same time, you want to develop a strong purpose in life that helps you hold on to hope despite adversity. So this is what shift and persist is. The persist part is having a purpose persisting on the focus of that purpose, helping you organize the important things that matter most in your life. I'm reminded as you're asking this question, there's a type of broken pottery art in Japan called kintsugi.
你接受你会有压力源的事实。同时，你想要在生活中培养一个强大的目标，这能帮助你在逆境中保持希望。这就是“转变与坚持”。坚持的部分是拥有一个目标，并坚持关注那个目标，帮助你组织生活中最重要的事情。当你问这个问题时，我想起了日本的一种碎陶艺术，叫金缮（kintsugi）。
I believe it's Japanese for golden repair, where you are mending broken pottery with a precious metal. And it treats breakage and repair as part of the history of an object rather than something to disguise. It happened in my own life too, with my daughter. I mean, we talk about it because it's part of our lives. We don't want to disguise it. It's part of our history. But I think it's also part of our lives. We don't want to disguise it. It's part of our history. But I think it's also part of our strength.
我相信这是日语中“金色的修复”的意思，即用贵金属修补破碎的陶器。它将破损和修复视为物体历史的一部分，而不是试图掩盖的东西。这在我的生活中也发生过，关于我的女儿。我的意思是，我们谈论它是因为它是我们生活的一部分。我们不想掩盖它。它是我们历史的一部分。但我认为它也是我们力量的一部分。
When people think about purpose, they sometimes confuse purpose with having a goal. I want to make a million dollars. I want to become the governor of my state. You say it's important to have a Self-transcending purpose. What do you mean by that idea Vic? Whenever we talk about purpose we have to talk about what we value What are the core values in our lives? And if you're asking what do I value maybe the first place to look is on the wallpaper of your smartphone When you turn on your smartphone, what's there? For me, it's my two granddaughters, but for other people, it might be their sports car. It could be a work of poetry.
当人们思考目标时，有时会把目标与拥有一个目的混淆。我想赚一百万美元。我想成为我所在州的州长。你说拥有一个“自我超越的目标”很重要。维克，你所说的这个想法是什么意思？每当我们谈论目标时，我们必须谈论我们重视什么。我们生活中的核心价值观是什么？如果你问我重视什么，也许第一个要看的地方是你智能手机的壁纸。当你打开智能手机时，上面有什么？对我来说，是我的两个孙女，但对其他人来说，可能是他们的跑车。可能是一首诗。
It could be a work of art. There are many things, a work of nature, many things people put on their smartphone, but what that tells me almost right away about a person is what they value. Our core values could be very transcending and related to peace, kindness, love, compassion, or they could be very self-enhancing. They could be related to my appearance or my wealth or what other people think about me. And it turns out that those values have different outcomes for people. People who tend to care more about these self-enhancing or what we might call hedonic values tend to not do as well as people who have self-transcending values. Even Aristotle said, we all have hedonic values and we all have what he called eudaemonic
可能是一件艺术品。有很多东西，大自然的作品，人们在智能手机上放很多东西，但那几乎立刻告诉我关于一个人的信息就是他们重视什么。我们的核心价值观可以是超越性的，与和平、善良、爱、同情心有关，也可以是非常自我提升的。它们可能与我的外表、我的财富或别人对我的看法有关。事实证明，这些价值观对人们有不同的结果。那些倾向于更多地关心这些自我提升或我们所说的享乐主义价值观的人，往往不如那些拥有自我超越价值观的人做得好。甚至亚里士多德也说过，我们都有享乐主义价值观，我们都有他所说的“尤达蒙尼”（eudaemonic）
values. Eudaemonia is being in touch with your inner daemon or true self or godlike self. The daemon was almost an angel that lived inside of us in ancient Greece. And he said, we all have both of those, but if we only live according to hedonic values, then we are like, and I'm quoting him from Nicomachean Ethics, then we are like grazing animals. We all like to graze, but at the same time, we need to transcend and live to this higher self, which is what Aristotle talked about 2,00 years ago, and now turns out to be true scientifically. People with transcending values have less activation in a part of the brain that relates to fear and aggression called the amygdala.
价值观。“尤达蒙尼”是指与你的内在守护神或真我或神性自我保持联系。在古希腊，守护神几乎是一个住在我们体内的天使。他说，我们都有这两种价值观，但如果我们只按照享乐主义价值观生活，那么我们就像——我引用他《尼各马可伦理学》中的话——那么我们就像吃草的动物。我们都喜欢吃草，但同时，我们需要超越并活出这个更高的自我，这就是亚里士多德在2000年前谈到的，现在科学证明这是真的。拥有超越性价值观的人，大脑中与恐惧和攻击性相关的部分（称为杏仁核）的激活程度较低。
They have more activation in a part of the brain that relates to what our self is. Executive decision making, long-term orientation, a future orientation, and that's called the ventral medial prefrontal cortex. Right up in the front of the brain, it's a very modern part of the brain. Humans have more than any other animal by a large amount. You told me that after Julia passed away, you made your purpose trying to teach every student who comes your way as if he was your son or she was your daughter How successful have you been at doing this week?
他们大脑中与自我相关的部分有更多的激活。执行决策、长期导向、未来导向，这被称为腹内侧前额叶皮层。就在大脑的前部，这是一个非常现代的大脑部分。人类拥有的数量比任何其他动物都要多得多。你告诉我，朱莉娅去世后，你的目标是尝试像对待自己的儿子或女儿一样去教导每一个来到你身边的学生。维克，你在这方面做得有多成功？
Well, of course, I don't really want to be their parent and they don't want me to be their parents So I should state that on the at the outset at the same time if a student comes to me and says I Really need your attention. I really need to see you, and I'm very busy and I'm maybe writing a grant proposal and I feel I just don't have time to see this person, then I ask, if I were the parent of that son or daughter, what would I want that professor to do? And so, if at all possible, I make time for that student. I'm not perfect at that by any means, but that is my goal. And it actually helps focus my attention and my energy, these very important
嗯，当然，我并不真的想成为他们的父母，他们也不想让我成为他们的父母。所以我应该在一开始就说明这一点。同时，如果一个学生来找我说，我真的需要你的关注。我真的需要见你，而我非常忙，可能正在写一份拨款申请，我觉得我实在没有时间见这个人，那么我会问，如果我是那个儿子的父母，我会希望那个教授怎么做？所以，如果可能的话，我会为那个学生腾出时间。我绝不是完美的，但这就是我的目标。它实际上有助于集中我的注意力和我的能量，这些我身体里非常重要的
resources that I have in my body, my attention and my energy, and it defocuses around things that are not important really, and yet we spend so much of our time engaging in. When we come back, how to identify a purpose for your life and align your everyday activities with your reason for living. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. Victor Strecker is a public health researcher at the University of Michigan.
资源，我的注意力和我的能量，并使我不再关注那些并不重要，但我们却花费了大量时间参与的事情。回来后，如何确定你的人生目标，并将你的日常活动与你的生活理由保持一致。你正在收听《隐藏的大脑》（Hidden Brain）。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆（Shankar Vedantam）。这是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。维克多·斯特雷克（Victor Strecker）是密歇根大学的公共卫生研究员。
He's the author of Life on Purpose. How living for what matters most changes everything. Vic you say that one of the first steps to finding our purpose is to determine what we value. You suggest people pick a few things from a long list of possibilities. What's on this list? When people think about their values, it could be values that are like money. It could be appearance.
他是《有目的的生活：为最重要的事情而活如何改变一切》（Life on Purpose: How living for what matters most changes everything）的作者。维克，你说寻找我们目标的第一步是确定我们重视什么。你建议人们从长长的可能性列表中挑选几样东西。这个列表上有什么？当人们思考他们的价值观时，可能是像金钱那样的价值观。可能是外表。
It could be what people think about you. You know, there are a lot of hedonic values and everybody has those to some extent, but there are also transcending values, self-transcending values, meaning values that are bigger than yourself. So values such as compassion. I really think one of the most moral values to consider is kindness to strangers. We're all kind probably, or most of us are kind to our family members, our loved ones. But can you be kind to people you don't know? I think that's a very self-transcending value. The things that people value very often aren't things, they're people. But when there are people who go beyond your direct sphere of knowledge,
可能是别人对你的看法。你知道，有很多享乐主义的价值观，每个人在某种程度上都有这些，但也有超越性的价值观，自我超越的价值观，意味着比你自己更宏大的价值观。比如同情心。我真的认为最值得考虑的道德价值观之一是对陌生人的善意。我们可能都很善良，或者我们大多数人对我们的家人、我们所爱的人都很善良。但你能对你不认识的人善良吗？我认为那是一个非常自我超越的价值观。人们重视的东西往往不是事物，而是人。但当有人超越了你直接的知识领域时，
and you can build purposes around that, that's what I would call a truly self-transcending purpose. You said that once people identify their top values, the top things they care about, they should spend some time thinking about, or better yet, writing about why each value is important to them. Why is this? What does that do? This is a process we call self-affirmation. So the idea of affirming who you are when you're
你可以围绕这一点建立目标，这就是我所说的真正的自我超越目标。你说过，一旦人们确定了他们的最高价值观，即他们最关心的前几件事，他们应该花一些时间思考，或者更好的是，写下为什么每个价值观对他们很重要。为什么会这样？那有什么作用？这是一个我们称之为“自我肯定”的过程。所以，当你肯定你是谁时，
affirming your core values, it's almost like you're affirming these are the roots in my tree, of my tree. This is like the bedrock of who I am. From that, my strengths grow, kind of the trunk of the tree. And from that, my behaviors and my emotions develop and respond, which are almost like the branches of our tree. But I like to start not with the behaviors, but with that root system. And starting with our core values, that is where we build our purpose. You see that another step is to boil down our values into a statement of purpose, what you call the headstone test. What is the headstone test? Well, I think the idea is what would you want people to say about you 100 years from now,
肯定你的核心价值观，这几乎就像你在肯定这些是我树的根。这就像是我之所以为我的基石。从那里，我的力量成长，就像树干一样。从那里，我的行为和情绪发展并做出反应，这就像我们树的树枝。但我喜欢从根系开始，而不是从行为开始。从我们的核心价值观开始，那就是我们建立目标的地方。你看到另一个步骤是将我们的价值观浓缩成一个目标陈述，你称之为“墓碑测试”。什么是墓碑测试？嗯，我认为这个想法是，你希望人们在100年后怎么评价你，
200 years from now? Jonas Salk once said late in his life, we should all be good ancestors. And I love that quote because I think back, I would think back to times I've walked through a cemetery. I love walking through a cemetery and I love looking at really old headstones and seeing what's on those headstones. But even more importantly, what would be said at your memorial service? What kinds of people would be at your memorial
200年后？乔纳斯·索尔克（Jonas Salk）晚年曾说，我们都应该成为好的祖先。我喜欢那句名言，因为我回想起来，我会回想起我走过墓地的时光。我喜欢走过墓地，我喜欢看非常古老的墓碑，看看上面写着什么。但更重要的是，在你的追悼会上会说些什么？什么样的会参加你的追悼会？
service? What kind of legacy are you leaving? When you start thinking about that, you start then thinking about how you live your life. As I was writing my book, Life on Purpose, writing my book, Life on Purpose, the editor gave me really good advice. He said, write your book review first before writing your book. And I said, why? I don't even know what I'm going to write. He said, exactly. I want you to write about what you want people to think and feel as a result of reading your book. And it turned out to be fabulous advice. I understand that you are working with collaborators to develop an AI system that can help people identify their goals. Tell me about this work.
服务？你留下了什么样的遗产？当你开始思考这个问题时，你就会开始思考你如何生活。当我写我的书《有目的的生活》时，编辑给了我非常好的建议。他说，在写书之前先写你的书评。我说，为什么？我甚至不知道我要写什么。他说，正是如此。我希望你写下你希望人们在读完你的书后有什么想法和感受。事实证明这是一个极好的建议。我知道你正在与合作者开发一个人工智能系统，可以帮助人们确定他们的目标。告诉我这项工作。
Well, yeah, we've developed an app called Purposeful, and Purposeful helps identify what your core values are, first of all, and what areas of purpose you want to focus your attention on. It could be your family, it could be your work, it could be the environment, many other things, and you can choose more than one thing. And then it starts identifying areas of growth you'd like to engage in. But importantly, for the last year, we've been working on an AI coach to help you write a purpose statement.
嗯，是的，我们开发了一个名为“Purposeful”的应用程序，Purposeful首先有助于确定你的核心价值观是什么，以及你想把注意力集中在哪些目标领域。它可以是你的家庭，可以是你的工作，可以是环境，还有许多其他事情，你可以选择不止一件事情。然后它开始确定你想要参与的成长领域。但重要的是，在过去的一年里，我们一直在开发一个人工智能教练来帮助你写目标陈述。
Because one of the things we've encountered is so many people have a hard time getting over that hump of actually writing a purpose statement. They say, well, that's too hard. It's going to be too big. It's going to make me stressed out. Or very often those purpose statements look like hallmark cards. I want to change the world. I want to help people. They're too vague. It's nice to have an authentic and specific purpose. And the purpose can be in multiple domains, like your work, like your family, like your community, like your own personal growth.
因为我们遇到的事情之一是，很多人很难跨过真正写出目标陈述的那道坎。他们说，嗯，那太难了。那会太大了。那会让我感到压力。或者通常那些目标陈述看起来像贺卡。我想改变世界。我想帮助别人。它们太模糊了。拥有一个真实且具体的目标是很好的。目标可以存在于多个领域，比如你的工作、你的家庭、你的社区、你自己的个人成长。
You can set goals and set a purpose around each of those domains. So to make a statement that's specific motivates you. And it actually motivates you to take better care of yourself. One essential component of pursuing a purpose-driven life is to not spend a lot of time on things that are not aligned with that purpose.
你可以围绕每一个领域设定目标并设定一个目的。所以，制定一个具体的陈述会激励你。它实际上激励你更好地照顾自己。追求目标导向生活的一个基本组成部分是不要把大量时间花在与该目标不一致的事情上。
Can you talk about this, that it's not just following what we should care about, but it's also not following what we shouldn't care about? I wonder if we did a time-motion study of everybody's lives and could parse out the part that really matters a lot to us and the part that really matters a lot to us and the part that really doesn't matter to us that we're doing just due to habit. Maybe there's social media engagements that don't really matter. Maybe I am worried
你能谈谈这一点吗，即这不仅仅是遵循我们应该关心的东西，而且也是不遵循我们不应该关心的东西？我想如果我们对每个人的生活进行一次时间-动作研究，并能解析出真正对我们很重要的一部分，以及真正对我们很重要的一部分，还有那些我们仅仅因为习惯而做的对我们并不重要的一部分。也许有一些社交媒体互动并不重要。也许我担心
about what Kim Kardashian is wearing today. Whatever those things are, you have to stop and ask yourself, are these really important to me? Are these important to my purpose and my goals that are these really important to me? Are these important to my purpose and my goals that I've set in my life? Are they important to my core values? And I would guess that a large portion of our time is spent engaged in things that are not all that important. Now, sometimes you need downtime. Sometimes you do need to just chill out and do something or watch something that may be meaningless. I understand that. But at the same time, how much do we spend? How much effort do we spend on those activities?
今天金·卡戴珊（Kim Kardashian）穿什么。无论那些事情是什么，你都必须停下来问自己，这些对我来说真的重要吗？这些对我为生活设定的目标和目的重要吗？它们对我的核心价值观重要吗？我猜我们很大一部分时间都花在了并不那么重要的事情上。现在，有时你需要停机时间。有时你确实需要放松一下，做点什么或看点什么，即使那可能毫无意义。我理解这一点。但同时，我们花了多少时间？我们在这些活动上花了多少精力？
So I understand some time ago, you were somewhat obsessed with frequent flyer miles. Was this connected to your purpose, Rick? As a public health professional, I was traveling around the world a lot, and I started, you know, counting my frequent flyer miles, which is certainly a goal, right? How many frequent flyer miles? I want to get to this status. I want to get to this status. And finally, I started realizing, wow, I'm going to go to my grave with the number of
所以我理解前段时间，你对飞行常客里程有些痴迷。这与你的目标有关吗，里克？作为一名公共卫生专业人士，我经常在世界各地旅行，我开始，你知道，计算我的飞行常客里程，这当然是一个目标，对吧？多少飞行常客里程？我想达到这个级别。我想达到那个级别。最后，我开始意识到，哇，我要带着这些数字进坟墓了，
frequent flyer miles on my headstone. It'll just say, he got palladium status. He got to fly the plane. He got to dance with a flight attendant. He got to play any music he wanted, things like that. And I thought, oh my God, this is maybe not what I want on my headstone. How did you switch off from that habit?
飞行常客里程在我的墓碑上。上面只会写着，他获得了钯金级别。他可以驾驶飞机。他可以和空姐跳舞。他可以播放任何他想听的音乐，诸如此类的事情。我想，天哪，这可能不是我想写在墓碑上的东西。你是如何从那个习惯中转变过来的？
After a while, I try to be a researcher of myself. And I hope everybody listening to this may think, can I become a better researcher of myself? And all that means is carefully observing your life and what matters to you, what you're spending your time on, what you're spending your time thinking about, what you're obsessed with. Are those the right things to be obsessed with? And some of them may well be and some of them may well not be. And then you have to say, my life is very finite.
过了一段时间，我尝试成为自己的研究员。我希望听到这个节目的每个人都能思考，我能成为更好的自我研究员吗？这意味着仔细观察你的生活以及对你重要的事情，你把时间花在什么上面，你把时间花在思考什么上面，你痴迷于什么。那些是值得痴迷的事情吗？其中一些可能是，而其中一些可能不是。然后你必须说，我的生命是非常有限的。
I'm here for this very brief time on this planet, an infinitely brief time. And what am I going to do with that brief time? Am I going to really spend a lot of time on social media or watching a lot of TV that I really don't care about? Or spending my time in arguments or spending my time listening to things that I have no control over? Maybe I do have control over certain things. I have some agency over certain things.
我在这颗星球上度过这极其短暂的时间，一段无限短暂的时间。我要用这段短暂的时间做什么？我是要真的花大量时间在社交媒体上，或者看很多我并不关心的电视节目吗？或者把时间花在争论中，或者把时间花在听一些我无法控制的事情上？也许我确实可以控制某些事情。我对某些事情有一定的能动性。
Maybe I can make a difference in this world during this brief time that I'm here. Maybe I can leave a legacy. Maybe I can be a good ancestor. I'm wondering what you think your daughter Julia would make of the way that you have lived your life since she passed away Vic I Try to live my life in a way that Julia would have wanted me to live my life Very often when I'm conflicted about something I turn to her and I ask
也许在我在这里的这段短暂时间里，我能在这个世界上有所作为。也许我能留下遗产。也许我能成为一个好的祖先。我想知道你认为你的女儿朱莉娅会如何看待你去世后生活的方式，维克。我尝试以朱莉娅希望我生活的方式来生活。每当我因为某事而感到矛盾时，我就会转向她，我问
What should I do? How would you recommend I make this decision? And it's very helpful. In our companion story on Hidden Brain Plus, we look at some of the surprising findings about the effects of having purpose on our immune systems and our brains. If you've ever found yourself worrying about Alzheimer's disease or heart attacks, you might want to listen to this one. If you're a subscriber to Hidden Brain Plus, that episode should be available in your feed right now.
我该怎么办？你建议我如何做出这个决定？这非常有帮助。在《隐藏的大脑Plus》（Hidden Brain Plus）的配套故事中，我们研究了一些关于拥有目标对我们的免疫系统和大脑影响的惊人发现。如果你曾经发现自己担心阿尔茨海默病或心脏病发作，你可能想听听这一集。如果你是《隐藏的大脑Plus》的订阅者，那一集现在应该可以在你的订阅源中找到。
It's titled, You 2.0, The Power of Finding Purpose. the power of finding purpose. If you're not yet a subscriber, please sign up at support.hiddenbrain.org. If you're using an Apple device, please go to apple.co. slash hiddenbrain. Victor Strecker is a public health researcher at the University of Michigan. He's the author of Life on Purpose, How Living for What Matters Most Changes Everything. Vic, thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thank you. It was a real pleasure. Do you have follow-up questions for Victor Strecker?
它的标题是《你2.0：寻找目标的力量》（You 2.0, The Power of Finding Purpose）。寻找目标的力量。如果你还不是订阅者，请在 support.hiddenbrain.org 注册。如果你使用的是苹果设备，请访问 apple.co/hiddenbrain。维克多·斯特雷克是密歇根大学的公共卫生研究员。他是《有目的的生活：为最重要的事情而活如何改变一切》的作者。维克，非常感谢你今天参加《隐藏的大脑》。谢谢。这真是我的荣幸。你对维克多·斯特雷克有什么后续问题吗？
If you'd be comfortable sharing those questions with a Hidden Brain audience, please record a voice memo on your phone and email it to us at ideas at hiddenbrain.org. That email address again is ideas at hiddenbrain.org. Use the subject line purpose. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Annie Murphy Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Quarell, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, Andrew Chadwick, and Nick Woodbury. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hiddenbrain's executive editor. Next week in our U2.0 series, how important is
如果你愿意与《隐藏的大脑》听众分享这些问题，请在手机上录制语音备忘录并发送电子邮件至 ideas@hiddenbrain.org。那个电子邮件地址再次是 ideas@hiddenbrain.org。使用主题行“purpose”。《隐藏的大脑》由《隐藏的大脑媒体》（Hidden Brain Media）制作。我们的音频制作团队包括安妮·墨菲·保罗（Annie Murphy Paul）、克里斯汀·王（Kristen Wong）、劳拉·夸雷尔（Laura Quarell）、瑞安·卡茨（Ryan Katz）、奥特姆·巴恩斯（Autumn Barnes）、安德鲁·查德威克（Andrew Chadwick）和尼克·伍德伯里（Nick Woodbury）。塔拉·博伊尔（Tara Boyle）是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行编辑。下周在我们的“你2.0”系列中，感觉你有一种使命感有多重要？
it to feel that you have a calling? We explore the role of passion in how we think about our lives. We also look at ways to regenerate interest in things that no longer excite you. I was feeling really low. I had a hard time to motivate myself to do more. Like I would stare at my computer screen in my cubicle and I just would ask myself what the heck I'm doing. That's next week in the second part of our U2.0 series. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们探讨了激情在我们思考生活方式中的作用。我们还研究了重新激发对不再让你兴奋的事物产生兴趣的方法。我当时感觉非常低落。我很难激励自己做更多的事情。就像我会盯着隔间里的电脑屏幕，我只会问自己我到底在做什么。那是下周我们“你2.0”系列的第二部分。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。很快再见。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。